foreign
[Music]
don't worry your boy's got this
hey over here kitty kitty
and down
I won't ask a second time
calling all Autobots roll out whoever
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
slow down
this is probably a lot for you oh I
thought after the car chase we were boys
what are you the name's Mirage come on
give me a little give me a little give
me a little give me a little tap
there you go now we're friends
oh great the gang's here they're more
like you
thank you
you brought a human here
I'm nobody I ain't even seen nothing I'm
not even seeing anything right now
there's a Darkness coming
let them come
[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again
prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
foreign
anything right now
stop
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
and
faced anything like this
let them come
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
when I voiced Prime for the very first
time I was living with my brother Larry
he was a marine and I said I'm going to
an audition I'm going to be a truck and
he started to laugh and he said he said
a truck and I said this is a leader this
is a hero and his demeanor just changed
he just went well Peter if you're gonna
be a leader be strong enough to be
gentle and I got to the audition and I
said my name is Optimus Prime from the
planet Cybertron I had no doubt that
this is what a hero should sound like
and I was convinced I was going to get
that rule
this is an emergency can you hear me
Mirage roll out here was that Peter
Cullen Gets behind that Mike and he goes
deep into Optimus Prime mode you're like
whoa this is really happening we have
one last hope Stephen cappell Jr really
is Sensational he's thoughtful he's
energetic he's moving he instills that
confidence to take the wheel
every Transformers movie Optimus Prime
and a lead human being are always close
and this is the first time in a film
where you see these two characters who
are trying to figure things out you
brought a human here Transformers rise
of the beasts has the same ingredients
that were there at the beginning there
is that Integrity there's a dignity
there's courage
it's an honor to be able to do this
character I've talked with a lot of
people that grew up with Transformers
and I don't take them for granted I love
you guys
this is Optimus Prime June 9th I invite
you to the movies
wow
we've seen the maximals and graphic
novels and we've seen them in a cartoon
but we have never seen them in live
actions
to protect the universe these are really
Larger than Life likeable character
there is more to this
air razor carries this sense of realness
with her but at the same time she's a
fighter
rhinox is a beast almost indestructible
it's a sense of family with the maximals
all as one
maximals maximize
it's about
to be crazy
this is about to be epically crazy
in chronological order this is the
second Transformers movie that takes
place during the 90s shortly after
Bumblebee
find a kid struggling with I was able to
provide for his family my character
noise ex-military and I feel like I'm
failing at every turn then I meet Mirage
[Music]
Pete Davidson is the voice of Mirage
he's kind of like the rebellious Autobot
you look a good man
go now we're
from Elena works at the Museum she's
investigating something which brings
Noah into her life who are you uh
janitor really and that kind of opens a
whole new world for us
[Music]
Journey with the Autobots we meet the
maximals
we meet the next level of feelings how
big can this guy be uh he eats planets
so like way bigger than a planet
action
humor
danger and there's a lot of Hearts
they're going against their biggest
Nemesis efforts
they've never based anything like this
before let them come
[Music]
thank you